who am i
[Applause]
what do you want to do with your life
frankie i don't know all right what kind
of stuff you want to make
i think you got potential i want to make
your next picture really
yeah what now yeah right now
yo what's up thanks for checking out
this video my little niece worships
these guys who do and say nothing
yo why is my existence so lit and
promote a lifestyle of doing and saying
nothing
hashtag swimming pool that's that
cocktail i just think this pineapple
life
you can't be following me like i'm no
one special man
you've got talent do you want to be the
guys that made two cool videos or do you
want to be
no one special this is the beginning
people came oh
my god we're all here
it's crazy how good this is huh
we have phone or no phone i'm charles
melton and i'm here with no one special
then we have a game show that idea
good idea i love you know what's special
this is just feeling so bright
we're about to go stratospheric
you know i see you right you see me
don't hurt her
i love that jake
are you prepared to let the world see
the real you
he's not who he says he is your success
directly contradicts your message
doesn't know you tell viewers
they're stupid for watching us i want
you to wake up because you're getting
swept up
you're so jealous of him get the viewers
back up before we lose anymore
a prophet will not be accepted in his
hometown you get to lead the revolution
have you told me one single thing that
was true
hey myself
i'm no one special cut
that was great
[Applause]
you